Jeff Bezos is the richest man in the
world the richest man who's ever lived
in the world
Amazon his company is one of the
country's most valuable but the
company's tax payments are not keeping
up with this great wealth okay that's a
profound understatement here's one
example last year Amazon made five point
six billion dollars in profit they
netted that but they use tax credits and
other benefits to avoid paying any
federal income tax did you pay federal
income tax last year oh one of the
biggest companies are well paid none
nevertheless governments around this
country state and local are racing to
provide Amazon with even more perks and
tax breaks as it looks to choose the
site of its second headquarters because
masochism is very common among state
government headers Umaga is a financial
analyst a very smart one and she joins
us tonight
Heather thanks coming on thank you how
does it work that one of the biggest
companies in the world an American
company pays no federal taxes well
that's a good question I think this is a
nonpartisan issue president Trump has
stated that Amazon is a no tax monopoly
right both Democrats and Republicans
alike would say that we're in agreement
with that statement and that is not okay
although they do pay state and local
income taxes they pay zero federal which
is correct one thing they're actually
know the New York Times today left to
Amazon's defense in effect by said oh
that's not really true I mean they
instinctively defended a company for
paying no federal taxes this is how
upside-down our world that's unusual I
would expect most Democrats or a liberal
newspaper or source to back to not back
a big corporation paying zero federal
you wouldn't think that but it's a very
liberal corporation so maybe they see
themselves also here's a reason why why
they get away with it from the sources
various tax breaks right they're saying
that executive stock options are
allowing them to pay zero federal income
tax now it's not illegal these are tax
loopholes it's in our tax code our
current tax system so they're taking
advantage of that but it doesn't seem
right
or fare a company that raked in a
hundred and seventy five billion dollars
last year this just isn't right I'm sure
you paid more in federal tax well I did
so I haven't put tens of thousands of
people out of work like amazon has
they've hired a lot but they put many
more out of work they've destroyed many
more businesses and they've created look
I get it that's the nature of market
capitalism but they feel no obligation
to give back at all to the federal
treasury Treasury at all mm-hmm well
what's worse is that they're able to
grandfather and deferred taxes so
deferred taxes those that they've
delayed in the past which is perfectly
legal now they can have those taxed at
the lower corporate tax rate effective
January 1 of 21% versus 35% when the
income in revenue was earned in the
prior years 2014-2015 so I mean that's
ridiculous we would all love to resend
our taxes right and let me pay my lower
individual income right now because
individual rates are now taxed at a
lower bracket as our corporate corporate
rates and that's just a little bit
critical shouldn't be allowed no it
shouldn't
and yet you the default and even you
know the president said this during the
campaign the default for people in
business is well it's allowed therefore
you got to do it's also allowed to
scream obscenities at your elderly
parents but it's wrong and you shouldn't
do it no but it's a lie it's not illegal
okay there are a lot of things that
aren't illegal but they're they're moral
and so what is does any company ever say
you know what it's this is our nation
America we're going to give back a
little bit maybe do they ever say that
yeah well they should and and it gets
worse because at the state and local
level they're now offering tax
incentives for Amazon to put their
second headquarters in their town and
all that's a legitimate that's that's a
legitimate thing to want for your city
not at the expense of taxpayers right I
agree now Amazon we reach out to them
say did not respond one of the questions
I wanted to ask and done this does that
mean I stuff to pay my federal taxes you
do our viewers have to pay their
unfortunately as the current tax code
stands we do and that's just how okay so
we do but Jeff Bezos says I just want to
be totally clear Heather thank you for
straightening it out for us this is
turning me into like a crazy person